[Musica]
Buonasera a tre stanno algebra sempre
mio figher che i binari
quando ero triste mio nonno mi diceva
sempre non piangere i bambini grandi non
piangono mai
Anche se molti anni più tardi questa
cosa mi capitò soprattutto se ero solo
in macchina e sentivo la radio Piccola
stella senza cielo di Ligabue
cosa ci fa e in mezzo a tutta questa
gente
quella canzone mi tirava un brutto
scherzo perché mi faceva pensare a mio
figlio
quello per me era un brutto periodo la
notte non dormivo così uscivo a correre
e finivo per parlare a una stella come
fanno i folli
così le chiedevo che ne sai tu della
diversità
nulla mi diceva con voce grossa Io sono
uguale alle altre che brillano nel cielo
qui sulla Terra invece esistono diverse
abilità diversi ideologie diversi
bisogni e tutta questa diversità rende
originale poiché l'omologazione non è
mai stata seducente essere diversi
Invece sì perché significa libertà di
essere ciò che si è
anche se in certi casi la diversità è
un'accezione negativa
perché mi chiese la stella
perché si odia il diverso colore della
pelle si odia un diverso orientamento
sessuale si odia al Dio a quale credere
e poi ce n'è un altro Quello che è
capitato a me la diversità che ti getta
nella paura quando ti bussa in casa
un giorno del 2001 la neuropsichiatra in
vita a me e mia moglie per parlare di
nostro figlio
mia moglie che è una docente con un
passato da insegnante di sostegno cerca
di anticiparmi qualcosa dicendomi penso
di sapere quello che ci dirà Leo è
autistico
a tre anni le rispondo a tutti il tempo
per guarire e crescere
Allora lei mi guarda dritto negli occhi
e mi dice
Guarda che l'autismo non è che sicuro
come un raffreddore è qualcosa di
permanente
così andiamo con l'incontro un filo
agitato entriamo in quell'ufficio ci
sediamo E
la neuropsichiatra conferma quello che
aveva anticipato mia moglie dicendo
abbiamo riscontrato Su vostro figlio una
sindrome di spettro autistico
mia moglie piange
io rimango inebetito poi improvvisamente
mi alzo in piedi di scatto Pensando
quello orribile parola che è spettro
è da far quel devi fare qualcosa mi dico
Che cosa qualsiasi cosa in passato hai
reagito alle tue difficoltà con rabbia e
sudore e adesso
no mi sa che questa volta sia un altro
campionato questo
però capisco che devo capire è una volta
arrivato a casa cerco nel dizionario il
significato della parola autismo
autismo infantile precoce sindrome
insorgente nei primi anni di vita che si
manifesta con profondo distacco
dall'ambiente
comportamenti motori ripetitivi e
monotoni indifferenza e consueti di
atteggiamenti linguaggio assente o
comunque privo di valore comunicativo
mi dico diventerà un bambino che starà
sulle sue non è così grave
poi continuo a leggere
in psichiatria la perdita del contatto
con la realtà e la costruzione di una
vita interiore propria che alla realtà
viene anteposta come condizione propria
della
schizofrenia e alcune manifestazioni
psico nevrotiche
benvenuti nel mondo della paura
la paura di aver sbagliato come genitore
è già in partenza come la vegli
trasmesso qualcosa di sbagliato
sei incompetente per come poterlo
aiutare perché quella sera la
neuropsichiatra non ti ha consegnato il
libretto delle istruzioni sul come ci si
comporta in questi casi
rimane lì
paralizzato dalla paura
privo di reazione L'unica che ho avuto è
stata quella di tatuarmi un drago nel
braccio destro Perché Leonardo piacciono
tantissimo i draghi
Intanto però la gente intorno a te si
allontana perché la sofferenza spaventa
quando tocca gli altri magari dopo aver
osservato attentamente mio figlio
notando che la sua natura lo porti
sempre
a nascondersi in un mondo tutto suo
fatto di spasmi motori e di fogli risate
come facevano un tempo in macchina e
manicomi
Ora ti prego Stella Dimmi come posso
aiutare mio figlio
a Stella Non parlò ma cominciò a
brillare molto ma molto di più e dietro
quella sua luce sfavillante mi rispose
ribellati
ribellati al tuo paura con un sorriso
rido da solo come fa mio figlio
ma questa volta è tutto diverso un
giorno a casa lo osservo meglio senza
provare pena per lui e mi accorgo che
ride Sì ma per un preciso motivo è una
cosa tutta sua sono le immagini più
esilaranti di alcuni cartoni animati che
guarda e riguarda decine di volte al
computer
E allora Dato che anche a me piace sia
ridere che inventavi storie e mi dico
facciamolo insieme
e Leonardo Hai presente la scena di
Jasmine Aladdin con il tappeto magico
Lui mi dà udienza Partiamo bene
cominciano a cantare mentre il tappeto
volando non li porta in giro per il
mondo ricordi come faceva la canzone
ora vieni con me
verso un mondo di incanto principessa e
tanto che il tuo cuore aspetta un sì
e improvvisamente il tappeto comincia a
precipitare così che Aladdin Preso dal
panico urla come tipo
e poi gli dice gli scappa anche un
tappeto di merda
[Musica]
e finiscono per cadere su una sabbia del
deserto senza farsi male
le euride e poi mi domanda ma perché
dice tappeto di merda
perché Leonardo i tappeti magici Non
esistono
finalmente avevo stabilito un contatto
con quel mondo
inserendomi tra quelle folle risate Dai
allora
oggi Leonardo dipinge
fa delle mostre
lavora come grafico
recitano una compagnia teatrale ed esce
la sera a mangiare la pizza con gli
amici questo grazie a sua madre e la sua
visione razionale nel voler inserire in
questa società
mentre io sono quello che con lui
condivide il tavolo della cucina lui da
una parte dipinge e io dall'altra parte
scrivo ma insieme inventiamo un sacco di
storie da sbellicarsi dalle risate
ma non molto tempo fa dopo averlo
accompagnato al lavoro Sono fermo in
auto o un semaforo
e sento in un radiogiornale una notizia
in un istituto privato di salute mentale
i carabinieri hanno arrestato alcuni
operatori sanitari perché dalle immagini
delle telecamere montate dagli
inquirenti si vede come gli ospiti
sono stati picchiati
e legati ai loro letti
Io lo so che la vita un ciclo e non
posso fare finta di non sapere che
quando io e sua madre non ci saremo più
Leonardo potrà andare a vivere in un
luogo come quello Istituto
ma una frustrazione legata a un lavoro
non può permettere della gente di alzare
le mani a persone che hanno un gran
bisogno di aiuto
Allora comincio a sentire un peso nello
stomaco
a respirare con affanno
e lei che torna più forte di prima
Bentornato paura
Allora nella notte insonne mi alzo e me
ne vado a correre in cerca della mia
stella e una volta trovata le dico
Ma lo sai perché in un rombo la notte
perché faccio un sogno ad occhi aperti
meraviglioso
immagino Leonardo essere un ragazzo come
tutti gli altri lì sul treno delle 7:27
quello che lo porterà in facoltà Sì
perché con tutto l'estro che si ritrova
sicuramente frequenterà il DAMS un
giorno si accorge della biondina quello
che lo guarda sempre quando sale sul
treno allora lui Sai che fa un bel
sorriso poi le si avvicina perché lui
non ha paura di mostrare i propri
sentimenti così le consegna un
auricolare delle sue cuffie lei lo
prenderà e sono infilerà nell'orecchio e
rimarrà a guardare mio figlio lì sul
treno delle 7:27 poi lui le farà un
inchino e la inviterà a danzare sopra
quelle dolci note finendo per
volteggiare nel corridoio della carrozza
senza che nessuno se ne accorga
Perché tanto a quell'ora c'è chi dorme
appoggiato al finestrino oppure chi ha
perso nel proprio telefono e una volta
arrivati quando le porte del treno si
apriranno Leonardo e la biondina
usciranno mano nella mano
andando incontro alla città
Eh
è una brutta faccenda essere genitori di
figli così speciali suoniamo per loro
sogni fantastici forse troppo mentre
nella realtà il mio posto è qua a metà
strada tra la follia di mio figlio e il
donargli una vita serena
ma
Come posso farlo se vivo una mera paura
Ogni volta che il suo futuro si fa
torbido
a quelle parole la stella scomparve dal
cielo
per non riapparire mai più
e allora mi sono venuti in mente le sue
parole l'ultima volta che ci siamo visti
Emanuele
al tempo uverar una risposta ma prem che
da scur verslavmenda il tempo ti darà
una risposta ma prima di dimenticare
della domanda ok
allora penso di aver trovato la mia di
risposta nonno
perché la paura è una buia deriva che ti
trascina verso l'ignoto mentre un
sorriso e luce
e trovare un equilibrio con la follia
Grazie